hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
agents of shield we totally got to see
Patton Oswalt and Adrian Pasdar we got
to raid the fridge and we learned a ton
more about Tahiti if you're finding me
for the first time I do bonus Marvel
videos every Tuesday be sure to
subscribe to get everything this week
it's gonna be Days of Future past they
just posted a new trailer and I have
some news on x-men apocalypse so I'll
have a link to that at the end of this
video
tonight's episode was so awesome so
let's just get right into it I'm gonna
start with my top 5 moments and then
I'll do my review careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet but here we
go
number 5 Garrett breaks Raina out of
prison so that she can resume project
centipede the whole goal of the project
was to make an army of super soldiers
phase 3 is basically them trying to
eliminate death using the things that
they learned in Tahiti there's also a
lot of tech in that equation to all that
centipede tech but Garrett actually
ended up revealing that some of his more
emotional mistakes in the past led to
his cyborg parts and so if they paid
major homage to the comic book version
of his character who had a bunch of his
human body parts replaced with cyber
parts it's a lot like what happened to
Mike Peterson you know getting turned
into Deathlok except Garrett's parts are
much less visible on the show but I
wonder what kind of upgrades he's had
back to Tahiti though we learned that
there was another scientist that was in
charge of the operation Nick Fury was
only the one to authorize Coulson's
treatment so I'm really curious as to
who that person was did anyone else get
the vibe that Raina might turn on
Garrett at some point she's all about
making the world better or whatever her
idea better is and I think that she sees
that Garrett doesn't care about making
anything better he's just more of a thug
so keep your eyes on her because she
might end up turning on Hydra before the
end of the season number 4 Ward is
everyone's type this was so much fun not
only was there some war drain of
shipping he also revealed how he got
everyone on Coulson's team to trust him
first he jumped out of the plane back in
episode 6 to save Simmons but then he
one upped it by starting to have sex
with Mae to throw her off the scent and
all he had to do to fool Coulson was
just play hard-to-get so funny the promo
for the next episode kind of spoiled
that Skye finds out that he's a double
agent and Patton Oswalt made this huge
speech to Coulson about vetting everyone
so obviously they're gonna find out
about him pretty soon I am still feeling
that by the end of the season he will be
back on Team Coulson in some form he
have explained his own backstory just a
little bit his real backstory and it was
all about Garrett pulling him out of a
terrible situation he didn't really
explain what that was but I think we'll
find out that because of the
relationship he formed with Garrett over
the years he got a little bit
brainwashed that is he drank a little
bit of the kool-aid I'm hoping that
he'll turn against Garrett eventually
and whenever he comes back to team
Coulson he and Skye will just be like
mate and Coulson you know teammates but
not super best friends anymore don't you
just get the sense this guy falls for
all the worst dirtbags like if I wanted
to go on a date with her all I have to
do is either one join Hydra or two just
become really really evil and she'd be
like yeah let's get that drink on to
number three Jared and ward pulled
graviton out of the fridge there's some
comedy in this situation and it's just
that we as the audience know that
gravitonium fused with Franklin Hall
back in episode 3 becoming graviton
essentially I think that whenever they
open that box it will just cause chaos
for everyone graviton was a villain in
the comic books but that doesn't
necessarily mean that he'll aligned
himself with Hydra and Garrett he might
just try to destroy both Garrett and
Coulson because of what happened to him
that's the funny thing it always seems
like when classic comic book heroes get
superpowers because of some freak
accident they get really really excited
about it and whenever villains get dosed
with radiation or something else they
always seek revenge
in all fairness though a lot of comic
book villains only became villains
because of the accidents that happened
to them
number two Garrett and ward totally raid
the fridge I actually thought this was
more fun than the graviton reveal at the
end how funny was it that the fridge is
actually on a beach
they were like kids in a candy store and
that scene where Garrett tells Ward
about project slingshot it's just so
hilarious
if it looks dangerous good if it looks
alien great really though after it was
all said and done my biggest question
was what happened to all the monkeys
that they shot into space and my number
one moment
Patton Oswalt becomes a agent of shield
I felt like he had the perfect
introduction on-screen that total nerd
moment when he's over explaining why the
base has no name they really took it to
the nth degree with the nerdy basement
metaphor as if he's been holed up
looking at porn and playing video games
by himself
in an underground bunker since the
Avengers that's a long time and a lot of
porn
I'm really glad he's coming back in next
week's episode and I wanted
see how he's gonna handle hide reward
after they find out that he's trying to
get the data on the hard drive but now
it's your turn let me know what your
favorite moment was was it raiding the
fridge or GERD and Raina just dosing
random people with that blue alien blood
or just evil ward in general with that
beard this is so crazy so here are
actually some of the bigger comic book
references that I spotted there was the
news report at the beginning talking
about all the leaked documents that
Black Widow released during Winter
Soldier
Garrett also gave her a nice shout out
whenever he was complimenting Ward for
infiltrating Coulson's team there was
the barber chair to the secret Hydra
base it totally felt like a reference to
that movie spies like us then when
Coulson's team talks about the cube
being retaken they're actually talking
about a black site like tahini from the
comics for a while it was used as a
prison for aliens I guess you could say
that the blue alien in Tahiti was also
in a prison of sorts when we see Glenn
Talbot it's a huge reference to the
whole comics he worked under general
Ross so you can imagine how he's gonna
deal with threats generally someone to
avoid at all costs and one of the most
fun references was the character of
Griffin Garrett talks about the person
they arrested that had lion's paws for
hands in the comics he was a normal
person who had surgery to make him look
like a mythical Griffin and he also got
dosed with this mutagenic serum thus he
became the super villain Griffin let me
know if you saw any other references
that I didn't mention in the video but
overall I gave the episode a solid a one
of the best this season so far
I think the Hydra and shield in chaos
plot has really added a sense of urgency
that the show hasn't had like the
ticking time bomb is just still waiting
to go off I love what they did with
Ward's character to at least now we know
why his performance has been so wooden
this year I definitely didn't dig the
Boy Scout aspect of his character it was
kind of like he was basing his double
agent performance on how he thought
Captain America would act in similar
situations which is kind of funny when
you think about it you know basically an
act on Captain America acting Patton
Oswalt there's also like a hyperspace
jump forward in the quality of guest
actors he's just so perfect for the role
he's playing I got this really meta Star
Wars flashback whenever - the term
popped up and fired like they were on
Hoth and it was the probe droid that Han
Solo and Chewie ran into then they just
kind of made me think about Patton
Oswalt's filibuster pitch for the plot
of Episode 7 just so meta and awesome
I'm
looking forward to the addition of
graviton into this mix with Deathlok
team Garrett and team Coulson all kind
of vying for what's left of shield like
all their resources I am kind of
wondering if it's gonna be Coulson's
team ultimately that's going to rebuild
shield or at least put most of the
pieces together supposedly by the time
the Avengers fight Ultron next year in
Avengers 2 shield will still be out of
commission but Coulson just seems so
adamant about upholding the virtues of
shield so obviously he's just gonna
continue on I did get really excited
whenever he did that big agents of
nothing speech but let me know what your
final thoughts are in the episode and
let me know what you think it's gonna
happen to agent ward before the end of
the season you know is he going to
rejoin Team Coulson but in other news if
you haven't seen it already I've posted
the x-men Days of Future Passed trailer
you can click right here to watch it and
you can click here to get my arrow
season 2 finale predictions thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives